- Hey guys, I'm Jasmine,
and today Rie is going to teach me
how to make one of her favorite
foods, she ate growing up.
- But, here is the catch.
(speaking Japanese)
Do you know any Japanese words?
- One word right before I eat.
- Okay (laughs)
- And it's 'itadakimasu'
- Oh, yes!
- Yes.
- Oh you speak well!
- Oh wow, thank you!
I can count to 10.
- Okay!
Do you want to show?
- Okay.
(counts to 10 in Japanese)
(applause)
(laughter)
- Pronunciation is so good!
- Really?
- Yeah!
- Well, part of my family is Japanese.
- Are you?
- My other side is half
Taiwanese, half Japanese.
- Oh wow!
- I'm half Chinese,
half Korean.
- I was going to give you lifelines,
but I think this dish is super easy
and you speak fluent Japanese. (giggles)
- I counted to 10!
- So.. (giggles)
No lifelines for Jasmine.
- What? (laughs)
Okay,
- No soup for you.
(laughter)
(speaking Japanese)
- Oh, 'junbi', prepare!
- (laughter) She knows!
She knows.
- It's also,
- What's the point
of doing this today?
(laughter)
- There's Japanese and
Mandarin that overlap.
- Really Like 'Junbi'?
- Yeah, like 'Zhǔnbèi'.
'Zhǔnbèi' is prepare.
- Ohh!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Since you're so good at it, (laughs)
- I'm not, I counted to 10 and
they took away my lifelines!
- And we added more ingredients.
Are you ready?
- Ready.
- Okay.
(speaking Japanese)
- Bowl!
- Yes. (giggles)
- How big?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Okay, a medium-sized bowl?
- How did she know?
- I presume?
I don't know. (laughs)
- See, like, basically
you understand (laughs)
- Well, I don't, I
don't, I'm just guessing.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Egg!
- See? (giggles)
- It's 'cause I like to eat Japanese food,
so the food part,
- Okay.
(speaking Japanese)
- Two, Two eggs!
- (speaking Japanese)
(speaking Japanese)
- Uh, crack the eggs into the bowl.
- (speaking Japanese)
(speaking Japanese)
- 'Dashi' broth.
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Sanbyaku', three byaku.
300 miliLiters?
- (gasps) Yes!
(laughter)
- I don't know what's happening.
- [Producer] How did you know that?
- 'Sanbya' sounds like 'sānbǎi'
which is 'three hundred'.
- Ohh.
- And I heard
- 'miririttoru' (laughs)
- Yeah, milliliters.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Add it into the bowl.
- Mirin?
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Ko', 'Five'?
- 'Kosaji', 'Kosaji'.
Two tablespoons of mirin?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Teaspoon?
Two teaspoons of mirin?
(Rie giggling)
- (speaking Japanese)
- I know sake!
(laughing)
I don't need to know how
much, I'll just feel it!
- 'Kosaji'.
- Five teaspoons!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Ni, two, two teaspoons!
Hai.
(exclaims in Japanese)
(laughter)
- More! How do you say 'more' in Japanese?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Motto!
(laughter)
- You put maybe a little too much?
- Too much sake?
Rie, this is not like you!
(laughter)
- We'll see, maybe this will
make it a better recipe.
- Exactly, yes.
- Yeah, okay.
- Great minds think alike.
- Experiment, experiment.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Soy sauce! 'Shōyu'.
- That's not..
'Shōyu'!
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Ichi', One.
'Ōsaji', Tablespoon?
- So 'Ōsaji' is tablespoon.
'Kosaji' is teaspoon.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- (speaking Japanese)
(both moaning)
(giggling)
- 'Hashi'.
- Nani?
(laughter)
- Can you guess?
- Mix!
- Yes!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Chopsticks.
- 'Hashi'.
- Hashi!
- (speaking Japanese)
Have you cooked Japanese food before?
- Oh yeah, I cook a lot of Japanese food,
but I don't, like, cook
in Japanese in my head.
I'll just be like,
I'm adding an egg, you know?
(laughter)
- (speaking Japanese)
- Christmas.
(laughter)
Christmas.
I don't know.
Put it to the side?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, strain it!
- Ooh, yummy!
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Tori'?
- Wine?
- (disapproving noises)
- Rice?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Cut, cutting board?
- Mm!
- I need a cutting board!
(laughter)
- So when you have cutting
board, what else do you need?
- A knife!
- Mm.
- 'Hōchō'!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Are you scared?
(laughter)
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Toriniku', chicken?
- Cut it into cubes.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Put it in a separate bowl.
- Wash my hands first,
- (speaking Japanese)
- and then we're going
to do the mushrooms.
There's even soap in that!
I thought it was a fake soap dispenser.
(laughter)
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Shiitake'.
- Mm!
(speaking Japanese)
- I usually wash my mushrooms.
- (speaking Japanese)
(playful music)
(laughter)
- Do you always exit like that?
- Yes. You know me so well.
(giggling)
- (speaking Japanese)
- Remove the stems?
(gasps)
Really?
Actually?
- But I think there's only
a few things you can do, so,
but you are right! (laughs)
- You're like, I'm not
actually that impressed.
That's so easy.
- The 'ishizuki' is the stem.
- I usually just peel it off.
- Okay, yeah.
You do you.
- Oh, I love it.
Freedom.
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Iko?
- Mm.
(speaking Japanese)
- One, just one?
- Mm!
- Oh, I did three.
- You do you.
(laughter)
- So I cut it?
- Hai!
- Thin slice?
- (speaking Japanese)
- (laughs) Even before I even say like,
- (laughs) I'm just guessing!
- Do you know what I'm making today?
- No, I have no clue!
- Okay.
- Just thin slice?
How thin?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Regular thin, like this?
- Mm!
- Just one shiitake?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Separate bowl.
- Hai!
(speaking Japanese)
- Round?
- Mm!
- Bowl?
- Small bowl?
- Mm!
- Nesting bowl?
- (speaking Japanese)
- Ow!
- V.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Ow!
Cutting board, blue!
Blue!
Foil!
- (speaking Japanese)
- This one!
- I don't even know
what this is in English!
Ceramic plate.
- Mm!
(speaking Japanese)
(buzzing)
Chicken, ah chicken! (laughs)
- Chicken, chicken!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Three pieces of chicken.
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Another one.
- Mm!
- (speaking Japanese)
- One for me, one for you?
- Mm!
- This one with four chickens.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Mushroom!
- Mm!
- Just a couple of pieces?
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Egg.
- Mm.
- (speaking Japanese)
- A little, like,
- Pitcher?
- pouring thingy.
- Mm, yes.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Pour it in there, nana.
7/8 of the way full?
(laughter)
- Follow your heart!
- Follow my heart?
- Mm hmm.
- How do you say that in Japanese?
- (speaking Japanese)
- That's hard.
- It's more like, uh,
follow your first,
- Instinct.
- Yeah, instinct.
(speaking Japanese)
- 'Arumihoiru'?
'Arumihoiru'.
- 'Arumihoiru'.
- 'Arumi'...
- [Producer] I know what it is!
- (laughs) Katie knows!
- [Producer] I can hear it.
- 'Arumihoiru'.
- 'Arumihoiru'?
- (laughter) You're saying it!
- 'Arumihoiru'!
(laughter)
- Do you want to go look around?
- 'Arumihoiru'?
- I'm crying. (laughs)
- Aluminum Foil?
(laughs)
- How can you not? (laughs)
- Ha ha, she's crying!
(laughter)
How did you know that?
- 'Cause it sounds like aluminum foil.
- I did not hear that!
I did not hear that.
(laughs) Rie!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Cover it.
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- What's next?
- (speaking Japanese).
- A baking sheet.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Hot plate.
(speaking Japanese)
- Fry pan.
- 'Ni'.
- 'Ni', two fry pans!
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Mizu', water.
- How did you know 'mizu'?
- I like hot pot, and the
original flavor is 'mizu'.
- Original flavor?
- Yeah, this original, like, no flavor.
- Oh, like, (speaks Japanese).
- Y-yeah, that's right!
(laughter)
- So you learn a lot of Japanese
by going to restaurants.
- Oh yeah!
- (speaking Japanese)
- We're gonna put a
paper towel in the pan.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Put the little round
bowls on the paper towel.
- (speaking Japanese)
- And then water?
- Hai.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Halfway full.
- Mm!
(speaking Japanese)
- More.
- (speaking Japanese)
- High heat!
- Okay, high heat.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Hai.
- You already, (giggles)
(speaking Japanese)
- Cover.
- Hai!
(speaking Japanese)
- So we're going to put this
to the side and let it cook.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Two, 'niko', two.
- Oh, we need a second hot plate!
- Yes, that's right.
- What are we doing?
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Nabe', hot pot.
- Mm.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, more water.
'Mizu', I heard 'mizu'.
- Hai.
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Futtō'.
- Mm.
- Futtō, uh, cover?
- 'Futtō'.
- For boiling water.
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Shio', salt!
- Hai!
- Shio ramen is my favorite.
(laughter)
- Me too.
- It's the best!
- It's the best.
(speaking Japanese)
- 'Manaita', cutting board.
- Mm, wow, you remember!
- I'm remembering!
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Snap peas?
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- We're gonna slice it.
We're gonna strip this!
- Hai!
(speaking Japanese)
- My mom always tells
me to be more gentle.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Add salt to the water?
- More, cover.
- (speaking Japanese)
- A little bit of rice vinegar.
Check on our egg.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Um, it's boiling now.
- Okay.
- So, we're going to un...
- (speaking Japanese)
- Slightly uncover?
- Yes!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Lower the heat
- Hai!
- to medium heat.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Low, simmer.
(speaking Japanese)
- (speaking Japanese)
- Mm.
- Oh! 10, fif, 10, 5.
1, 5.
15 minutes!
- Yes.
- Yes, yes, yes!
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Kōrimizu'.
Water.
- Kōri.
- Cold, water.
Ice, ice, ice, ice, ice!
- Yes, yes!
(speaking Japanese)
- Add water into the ice?
- Hai!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, snap peas?
- Hai!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, we're going to
make them crunchy here.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Okay, so we can take them out.
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Take it out.
- Mm.
- I know if you put food
too long in ice water,
it causes ice, like water clog.
- Ohh.
- So you should not
- Leave it too long.
- leave it too long.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Shrimp!
- Hai.
- [Producer] How do you know shrimp?
- Shrimp tempura is 'ebi' tempura.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Put it in the water?
- Mm, hai!
- How many?
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Ni', 'ichi, ni', two.
- We're going to take it out real quick.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Once it's cooked.
- Oh, when it's pink.
- Mm.
- We're going to take it out.
(laughter)
- (speaking Japanese)
- 'Kōrimizu', put it in ice water.
- Hai!
(speaking Japanese)
- Take it out.
- Hai.
(speaking Japanese)
- Peel the shrimp!
- Mm!
(speaking Japanese)
- Leave the tail.
- Mm!
- Wow, wow.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, 'Hōchō'!
I remember this, you said this earlier.
- Yes, 'Hōchō'.
- Knife!
- Hai!
- Yes, yes, yes!
- Yes!
- 'Hōchō'!
- Yes, yes.
(speaking Japanese)
- Snow peas.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Half!
- This way!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Diagonally half, like this.
- And then same with the others.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Put it to the side.
- 'Chawanmushi', 'Moshi moshi'.
- (laughs) 'Moshi moshi'.
- 'Moshi moshi'.
- 'Chawanmushi'.
- Oh we're going to check on our eggs.
- Yes!
- Okay.
(exciting music)
There's one.
- Oh!
- Oh, it's kind of set.
- I think it's a little loose
because you added so much sake. (laughter)
- No, I did not.
- It smells good!
- It smells amazing.
Must be all that sake
(laughter)
that I added.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, beautiful!
- 'Ebi', shrimp!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Do I have to cut it?
- Mm-mm.
- So I just place it on top?
- Hai!
- It's set enough to
- Hai.
- be placed on top.
- (speaking Japanese)
- Uh, snow peas.
- Put it beautifully.
- (speaking Japanese)
Oh nice, I like that!
(speaking Japanese)
- 'Ikura'
- Mm.
- Oh, caviar?
Oh, caviar!
- It's not caviar, it's salmon roe.
- Salmon roe.
Just a little bit on top.
- Mm.
- Wow, this is beautiful!
- Yeah it kind of pops the color, right?
- Yeah!
- (speaking Japanese)
- It's time to eat?
- Yeah!
- Yes!
- So I'm going to get mine
and we can compare yours and mine.
- Okay.
- Here is mine!
- I'm excited!
- Ta-da!
- Wow!
(applause)
- You did great!
I think you added too
much sake so it jiggles,
but it's brothy,
- Yes.
- and it looks delicious.
- Oh my God, you're so nice.
She's like covering up
my big, big mess up.
- Do you know what is this?
It's called 'chawanmushi'.
Have you had anything similar before?
- Yes. I make 'gyeranjjim',
which is like Korean steamed egg.
It's a similar process,
but I don't put too much love
and care into when I make it.
I kind of just throw it together,
mix it all up and then steam it.
- Oh yeah, I know which
one you're talking about.
- Yeah, the one, like, when
you go to Korean restaurants?
- Yeah! I thought it was tofu
'cause it's so fluffy
- It's so soft.
It's like so silky, right?
- Yeah. Mm hmm.
- It's so good.
- I can't wait you to try this.
- Should we try mine first?
- Yes.
- I hope you like it.
- Yeah, it looks great.
(approving noises)
So soft!
- Don't even need to chew.
- It doesn't taste like sake. (laughs)
- It doesn't!
It tastes like 'dashi' broth and mushroom.
- Delicious!
- (speaking Japanese)
- Good job!
- Thank you.
- All right, let's try mine.
- Okay.
- Still jiggly.
- Wow.
This really looks like tofu.
(giggles)
(approving noises)
- Yours taste different, yours
is like a little sweeter.
- I feel this tastes
actually better. (giggles)
- Really?
- Maybe I should bulk
up sake like you did.
(laughter)
- Well, thank you so much
for teaching me this recipe!
- Yeah, thank you so much!
It was fun.
- It's so delicious
- Mm, it's so good.
- Next time, it's my turn.
- Okay.
Thank you so much for watching!
- Bye!
- [Male Voice] Oh, yes!
(electronic outro music)